[Music]
[Applause]
Chris Smith Sports Business Journal
staff writer and he's covering this he
covers Sports Finance as well as
reporting on team sales other
Investments throughout the industry and
kind enough to join us on short notice
Chris is it just a coincidence that
these uh teams are being sold now in
part yes uh I mean I think we're seeing
a bunch of different reasons why these
teams are hitting the market you
mentioned the Broncos there was the
Senators up in Ottawa those are cases
where an owner died and The Heirs are
selling the team uh in other cases
there's a forced sale right you know
Robert Sarver in Phoenix Dan Snyder in
Washington those are situations where
Maybe the owner wouldn't want to sell
but there was pressure to that kind of
force those transactions uh and then you
know you have some situations where
there's an aging owner and maybe you
have heirs or children that either can't
afford or don't want to continue to own
the team and so they are making
transactions before their debts uh and
that maybe explain some of the other
ones we've seen um for instance you know
you race Baltimore is the most recent
one uh so I think handful of reasons uh
informing some of these transactions are
the numbers the uh teams their value
bloated is it like the housing
market uh it depends who you ask I would
say at this point still the overwhelming
sentiment is no uh the sense is that
these assets um there are a number of
reasons that explain why they are so
valuable uh you know namely that they're
recession uh resilient so we seen every
time there's been an economic downturn
we saw it during covid valuations have
not fallen in the way that other assets
have uh We've also seen that it's not
correlated to public markets which is
hard to find uh and so and thirdly and
maybe most importantly is the scarcity
there are very few of these teams and
they're not really making more of them
uh except for you know the occasional
expansion round and so you have some of
these uh really you know economic
justifications that would explain why
these teams are worth billions and
billions of dollars but also do you have
franchises that are losing
value we haven't really seen that yet um
you know I think one example there was a
sense that maybe the Cleveland Cavaliers
remember when LeBron James left that
team that that could be an example of a
team losing some value just because it
went from being you know one of the most
relevant teams in the NBA to not being
uh such uh but we haven't really seen a
decline yet and I think the question now
is as we're seeing some of the regional
Sports networks go under and face
bankruptcy uh and seeing you know maybe
some challenges to the fundamental model
for how these teams operate on the
business side uh you know the question
is are we going to see evaluations begin
to Plateau but we haven't really seen
that just yet but also if you're looking
at what is the best investment for your
money with the biggest upside so what
sport would you say would be the place
to put your money I think there's sort
of two ends of the spectrum on that one
is the NFL right the NFL is very top end
obviously the most valuable most
expensive teams uh they generate a
tremendous amount of cash uh you have
these National media deals that are
unrivaled across Pro Sports landscape uh
that is a space where I think there's
really no concerns there's going to be a
downturn on the other end of the
spectrum I would say something like
women's sports right we saw the nwsl
they have record transaction values it
feels like every few months uh Michelle
Kang acquires the Washington spe for $35
million uh expansion teams at a record
$53 million we're not seeing the team in
Portland sell for $63 million and it
feels like there's really a lot of
momentum in the women's sports space and
I think a lot of people especially
younger fans are now uh moving into
women's sports so there's a lot of
upside there uh so I say I would say if
that's one area and you're seeing a lot
of sophisticated a lot of smart
investors looking to women's sports uh
for that to you know capitalize on that
potential upside what was the impact on
lonel Messi with MLS as far as helping
other teams in their values I think you
well so Miami obviously has had a
tremendous explosion uh financially the
other teams it is hard to quantify just
yet but it's you know I think in MLS the
rising tide lifts all boats always uh
and with the World Cup coming in a few
years here to the United States and
broadly into North America uh I I think
there are a lot of people who are very
bullish on that space so if if
especially if you have more of these
bigname European players who are going
to follow in Messi's footsteps right and
have this talent that people care about
in a big way that's going to help in a
in a big big way and you just see you
know the kind of the media right deals
and sponsorships I follow those if you
could buy any team in the United States
what team would you
want uh for personal and financial
reasons I might go New York Yankees just
being a fan and uh you know I think when
you look at teams that you would want to
own you're looking for major markets
you're looking for Global Brands uh you
know these teams that are able to
generate uh tremendous amounts of
Revenue not just off of uh what they're
doing game day selling tickets selling
beers selling hot dogs uh but also have
the brand globally that they can
capitalize on uh so that might be top of
my list what about the Dodgers the
impact that sh how do you recoup that
money with
shohi uh I think there's a few ways I
mean one is that there's going to be a
whole lot more Revenue coming off of shi
signing right when you think about new
fans who are going to come to the team U
they're going to be able to sell much
much more merchandise they're able to
raise ticket prices raise prices in the
stadium could he be a
bargain yes because of the way that
contract was structured and with that
with that deferred money yeah you know
and you think about uh something like
inflation a long-term deal like that A
dollar is going to be you know a whole
lot less expensive to spend in 10 years
than it is now and so um you know it's
obviously to be determined whether he
can continue playing at this at this
rate and kind of for how long but if he
stays anywhere close to what he's been
doing the last few years uh that deal
could look pretty good in in another
decade or so great to talk to you Chris
doing a great job yeah thanks thanks for
joining
us that's uh Chris Smith Sports Business
Journal staff writer covering uh these
teams being sold